I'm Geraldo Rivera I'm Emily compagno
and I'm Eric Shawn this is a Fox News
Rundown
Friday December 16 2022 I'm Chris Foster
the first covid-19 cases were reported
in Wuhan China three years ago this week
and we're still dealing with the Fallout
including financially and politically we
would hope that in a moment of this
level of Crisis we could find some unity
and get beyond that stuff but
um the two sides clearly see this
pandemic in the way that it's rolled out
the way that it was handled very
differently we're speaking with Fox News
Sunday host Shannon bream I'm Jessica
Rosenthal Americans are gloomy about the
economy and some say the FED needs to
take its foot off the brake to avoid a
downturn even a recession as officials
try to tame inflation I think the FED
has been very much too tied and I think
that that could lead to a poor economy
into the future and I'm Delroy Murdock
I've got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
find administration's plan for a
possible winter surge in covid-19 cases
includes another round of free masks for
per household by request and continuing
to encourage people to get the latest
vaccines and there's a report out from
House Republicans saying there are
indications that virus originated with
biological weapons testing in China our
intelligence Community has not been
forthcoming with the American people
about what was going on in that lab
Kentucky house Republican James Comer on
Fox and then promising more
investigations when Republicans become
the House Majority next month it was
right around now three years ago when
the first case clusters were reported in
Wuhan China whether you look at mandates
or masks or vaccines you know people
definitely fall down on either side of
that many times because of where they
are politically Shannon bream's the host
of Fox News Sunday a lot of people feel
like we've learned a lot hopefully in
the last couple of years but we know a
lot more scientifically about how to
treat people how to save lives how to do
a better job at this so we have learned
through the process but I fear that as
we look on Capitol Hill there are still
hearings there will be more hearings to
come there are still accusations that
it's very political in nature when we
would hope that in a moment of this
level of Crisis we could find some unity
and get beyond that stuff but
um the two sides clearly see this
pandemic in the way that it's rolled out
the way that it was handled very
differently yeah their Mass
recommendations again in some cities New
York La I know maybe others I know
Philadelphia Public Schools apparently
have kids masking up and staff masking
up for the first two weeks back from
Christmas in case
you know people get it during Christmas
Gatherings holiday Gatherings at least
one New York State University campuses
has people massed up now indoors now
things get really bad like really bad
um and you mentioned treatments better
now but still if if things really really
explode this winter it's going to be
really tough to tell people now you
gotta mask up inside again sorry
um even in places where people really
went along with it
back in the day you're gonna have
business owners who aren't going to want
to follow through or reinforce it and
then you're going to get back to the
thing where you know retail clerks are
going to get yelled at or have to deal
with people who who don't want to wear a
mask or do whatever I want to wear a
mask
yeah and there's just a level of fatigue
I think people really in the beginning
most people were on the same page like
let's do what we can and protect
ourselves our neighbors the most
vulnerable Among Us let's rise to the
better Angels Among Us and I think after
you know almost three years of back and
forth and people feeling like they
weren't told the truth about things that
you know these big agencies and big
names
um like wolinsky and fauci and all these
others change their positions on key
issues people just there's been a loss
of trust in public medicine and in
public agencies in some ways that I
think yeah if you come back to people
now and say okay it's masks all the time
inside for everybody good luck enforcing
that I think enough people have said
um I've got real doubts based on studies
and based on what these medical leaders
have told us over time that that's even
really a definitive help I I just think
that there are so many questions people
have that they are now more willing to
ask questions than just go along as they
would have in the beginning when we were
all cheering for each other and hoping
for the best yeah it was also a lot
scarier in the very beginning too I mean
again there's more a lot of us are
vaccinated there are more treatments
um that the Republicans are going to
take the house next month and you know
that they're going to be among other
things they're going to be looking at
the covet Origins they're going to be
looking at the government response
people like Anthony fauci
um now there's this new report already
from the Republicans on the house
intelligence committee that says there
are indications the virus spilled over
from a biological weapons program that
contradicts an intelligence Community
report that came out last year that said
there are no covet links or they
couldn't find any covert links to buy a
weapons program I'm not sure we're ever
really going to know the truth given the
secrecy of the Chinese government
exactly and the fact that you know by
the time we did have any kind of outside
investigative body admitted it was
months if not a year into this and
China's never given full access to
Outsiders who wanted to come and ask
these questions and look around so I do
think that people are going to be very
open to hearing from these different
investigations and potential theories
because China was so tight-lipped about
this and remained so
um the interesting thing is that China
domestically now has a real problem with
this because they've tried to get to
zero covet and we know just the barbaric
lockdowns and limits and locking people
in their homes and all of the things
that we've seen and probably some of it
we don't know that hasn't been exposed
but the Western world looks at that and
just says okay there there is no way
we're going along with that stuff
um but there's just so much we're not
going to know because China is able to
control the flow of information with
regard to the origins of this whole
thing yeah in the end unless there are
major leaks coming from somewhere it's
it's is all going to be educated and
educated guesses moving on to some tech
stuff now The Tick Tock app
might be in a banned on federal
government phones that's already the
case in some states over concerns about
China and security now a lot of kids are
going to be really mad if this ever
turns into an actual National ban I mean
I'm sure but eventually they'll move on
to something else and they'll do their
dances and and and and stuff on on some
other app president Trump sounded the
alarm on this a couple years ago and
ultimately decided they decided against
a ban and the Chinese say look there's
nothing nefarious going on well and
remember when he floated that during his
administration there was this complete
meltdown like Republicans will lose the
entire Next Generation if you take
Tick-Tock away from these kids I mean
there was a lot of consternation over
that
um I had Senator Mark Warner um you know
a top Democrat on a couple of weeks ago
and asked him okay was Trump potentially
right about this and he's like I think
he might have been right and we should
have been listening and if we had taken
action a couple of years ago we might be
in a better space when it comes to this
now now you know there there are the
measures that are aimed at keeping Tick
Tock off government phones whether state
or federal but there are other lawmakers
who are actually trying to get it banned
altogether like it just wouldn't be used
in the domestic U.S market Tick Tock
continues to say we don't hold data it's
not you know in a way that it would be
what we happen have in our U.S market
would be subject to Chinese oversight or
to to Chinese law lawmakers just aren't
buying that anymore and there is it's
one of those few things there's a lot of
bipartisan agreement about this in
Washington in at a time when there's not
much bipartisan agreement on anything
that there are real threats with Tick
Tock so I wouldn't be surprised if they
continue to try to move forward on
legislation I mean India is a country
for example where it's banned altogether
then there are a number of folks on
Capitol Hill that seem to be trying to
get that Coalition together to do it
here too another thing that could be
getting more bipartisan support in the
new Congress is taking a harder look and
taking a harder stance on cryptocurrency
now we've got this FCX guy in custody
Sam bankman freed his cryptocurrency
exchange when belly up there was a the
equivalent of a bank run
um he says he made mistakes government
says he stole and you know he's in
custody now I can't imagine either way
that's going to be causing a lot of
casual investors to go rushing into
crypto and listen I am such a Luddite
when it comes to this stuff that it's a
constant learning process for me about
this crypto stuff and I would say for a
lot of our lawmakers too I mean Senate
Banking Committee had a hearing on
Wednesday where they called these folks
in the FTX CEO was there and others who
talked about how this should be
regulated
um and there it seemed to be that there
was this line of thought listen you
can't get rid of cryptocurrencies it
would be almost impossible to do that at
this point so the conversation has to be
about how you regulate it and I think
that was the you know one of the
problems with um Sam bakeman freed is
that he was really trying to work around
to ways of Regulation that he thought
would benefit him most or his company
most and
um this technology is developing so
quickly that the law has not really been
codified to catch up with it but
something of this massive nature that
happens is what will spark that
legislation and those regulations and I
think we saw in that Senate banking
hearing on Wednesday that there is going
to be a serious Crackdown on
cryptocurrency not that it won't exist
they seem to acknowledge you know that
ship has sailed but in the way that it's
going to be regulated now and there are
some lawmakers that want more regulation
of social media
as well
getting back to that Twitter we have
these Twitter files now where every few
days we get these internal documents
that come out they've been analyzed by
journalists and they you know these
internal documents with back and forth
about what posts what users to suppress
um now the charitable explanation is
that look these are human beings that
are just trying to make decisions about
moderation and how you know in their
terms of services yada yada and there
are those the less charitable
explanation there are those that say
look there's government control of this
stuff and um that might even raise rise
a level of illegality
I mean yeah you get into the situation
where when a private company is acting
at the direction of the government I'm
not saying that's what happened here
with Twitter but that legal Theory you
turn that private company in some ways
into a state actor or they're acting on
behalf of the government so those are
the questions people have when we find
out internally that there were weekly
meetings at some point with top Twitter
Executives and the FBI DHS the dni
office that Sparks real questions about
whether a government entity was
directing the internal policies and
actions of a private company because you
know if you have somebody who is caught
up in this so-called Shadow Banning
visibility filters whatever they want to
call it that decides to bring a suit I
mean that can be a theory for them that
listen the government was acting through
Twitter or causing them to act on behalf
of quelling My Free Speech under the
First Amendment um and I I just think
we're going to have a lot more at least
I do from what we've seen so far I have
a lot more questions than I do answer so
far with what we've seen from Twitter
but if I'm somebody who feels I was
wronged by these policies and these you
know blocking them from trending or
blocking their message from being you
know out in the public sphere I'd have
real censorship thoughts and that would
be the person who would have standing to
bring one of these suits yeah uh and and
president Trump's now unbanned he's not
on it for I assume business reasons
because he's got his true social going
on but
um now the decision to ban him we've
learned was kind of made up on the fly
but it kind of had to be made up on the
Fly because nobody ever a president had
never done that before yeah they've
never banned a sitting head of state so
that was a whole conversation like do we
do we start kicking presidents and prime
ministers off Twitter do we how do we do
that and how do we try to carefully do
that and you can see there was angst
internally there were some people who
thought oh my goodness we're getting
into Uncharted Territory we need to be
very careful about how this goes down
and and there were those who had real
concerns that it would appear to be
censorship in a way that may be pushing
the line so yeah just to see these
internal conversations is fascinating
now Shannon bream's the host of Fox News
Sunday if we don't talk next week
Shannon happy birthday Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas
[Music]
this is to Roy Murdock with your Fox
News commentary coming up
kins do not have the rosiest Outlook
ahead for the economy the latest Fox
News poll finds 81 percent rate the
economy as only fair or poor nearly
three in four voters say inflation has
caused financial hardship for them over
the past six months and folks are
worried about next year with 48 saying
they think the economy will get worse
and only 25 percent saying it will get
better this is important because when
folks feel uncertain they tend to spend
less and their forecasts of tough times
becomes reality Fox Business Network
anchor Jerry Willis said a Deloitte
survey also found corporate Chief
Financial officers are largely not
optimistic about the outlook for their
own companies Thursday the Dow sunk more
than 760 points after November retail
sales showed up looking pretty weak they
were down point six percent compared to
October manufacturing output declined by
that much as well in the first drop
there since June Fox Business
contributor Brian brenberg said this
combined with the Fed rate hike
announced this week has Wall Street a
bit spooked they are hating this retail
sales number today which dropped much
more than expected you put that on top
of the FED yesterday and Powell's doing
his best Paul volcker impression saying
we're going to keep bringing rates up
everybody's reading that as oh this
recession could get very real look if
consumers back off and we're seeing a
little bit of that now that makes 2023
very very scary Federal Reserve chair
Jerome Powell said this week while
inflation at 7.1 percent was heading in
the right direction especially compared
to the summer and the housing market has
cooled tremendously the labor market is
still just too strong one where we
haven't seen much softening where job
growth is very high where wages are very
high vacancies are are quite elevated
and really there's an imbalance in the
labor market between supply and demand
so that part of it which is the biggest
part is likely to take a substantial
period to get down the obvious question
then is what is a substantial period as
some disagree with the fed's latest
moves it's the recognition in that the
FED is wrong again unfortunately Gary
calbaum is the president of calpbomb
capital and a fox business contributor
and you got to work backwards when the
FED printed nine trillion dollars took
rates to zero and created all kinds of
inflation and all kinds of Bubbles and
then they fell behind interest rates not
them but interest rates themselves
started to Skyrocket without them while
they were saying inflation was
transitory and there was nothing to
worry about finally they recognized that
something had to be done so they had to
start playing catch-up they have to
start raising rates they have to stop
printing money and they slowly caught up
but what something all else happened at
the same time is the economy hit a wall
and as you can see I I believe we're in
recession already
combine that with uh if you look at two
charts one of savings rates which are
just absolutely plunging and credit card
usage is Sky marketing since the
consumer seventy percent of the economy
that's big time worry so what's happened
now the actual Market of member interest
rates have now come down from 4.3
percent on the 10-year and that's where
mortgages uh sit down to under 3.5
percent but the FED hasn't recognized
that so they keep raising rates into a
big slowdown in the economy and a market
that's telling them to slow down and
since the market they're not listening
to the market you're seeing what the
Market's screaming about today and I
suspect there's going to be a bunch more
to go to the downside as the market
recognizes they're behind and the market
recognizes earnings have are going to
head down as well as the economy
you know after fed chairman Powell
announced the rate hike it sounded like
not that he was rooting for layoffs
necessarily but saying essentially that
that some layoffs more than we're seeing
are are needed in order to bring
inflation back down to this close to two
percent that that's obviously a very
gloomy take but how much more labor
market cooling would be needed
especially since we have like what 10
million job openings right now
yeah I think they're nuts unfortunately
uh you know Neil cash carry another fed
head uh the day after the Jackson Hole
speech a couple months back the market
dropped a thousand points and amazingly
one of our Central Bankers who
supposedly cares about stability says
I'm happy the market dropped a thousand
points and I'm thinking to myself
they're rooting for people to lose money
and now lose jobs these are our Central
Bankers that's worrisome and yeah
they're actually rooting for it and uh
which is unbelievable and amazing the
media hasn't been ripping them on them
they seem to be Teflon as far as any
criticism whatsoever you don't want to
see anybody lose jobs and I have news
for you Luke people losing jobs that's
not cure inflation well that was that
that's the point right Gary that that's
the central question is they're
maintaining that that not necessarily
rooting for job losses but that if the
goal is to keep inflation at two percent
and stop that suffering stop that
bleeding then there needs to be sort of
other bloodletting in another place
and there's no historical evidence that
in order to get rid of inflation you got
to kill the economy and kill the job
market I don't know where they get that
idea from we've had plenty of years uh
multi-years where we've had a great
economy uh great jobs and low inflation
oh gee it was the few years before uh
the last few years so I I don't know
what they're thinking my worries been
since uh Christmas of 18 there's just
too much of them and not of enough of us
if they would just leave the 200 and so
million people that go to work every day
wanting to do well for their family as
well themselves and let the markets be I
think the market is a lot more efficient
than they are and their interference and
guess what the the 10-year yield again
is back down to 3.4 percent and change
they're now sitting at four and a
quarter four and a half and saying
they're going to five so they're kind of
like stomping on the real market and the
that's where I think the markets are
worried and that's why I think you're
seeing what the Market's doing here and
I do believe we're going to be going
lower unfortunately
I think the FED is wrong but think the
wake-up call will come in the form of
the strength of the American economy and
that chair Powell will reconsider his
tightness of today in the middle of
2023. Jeremy Siegel is a professor of
Finance at the Horton School of Business
well first of all I am long run very
optimistic I think the FED has been very
much too tight and I think that that
could lead to a poor economy uh into the
future however I believe that they will
come to the recognition that we need
lower interest rates they will
eventually lower the interest rates and
that we could have a very good economy
in the second half of 2023.
I was going to ask you about the timing
of that um I've heard you say and you
just said it now the FED is sort of over
tightening it's it's basically too much
too fast what are you seeing that is the
current outcome or consequence of of the
too much tightening is it the housing
market for example or is it something
else
yeah well that's one of the factors but
uh I see inflation coming down
everywhere and even becoming deflation
in certain uh categories specifically
housing housing prices are going down
and rental prices are going down now not
year over year but month over month they
are going down so uh when I hear
chairman Powell talk about uh you know
oh inflation is it was bad or worse than
it was I do not see that at all and I
believe that he's keeping interest rates
too high listen the Fed was to blame for
the inflation we had with far too
expensive monetary policy in 2020 and
2021 and then suddenly you know Jay
Powell quote got religion and oh my God
now you know he's the biggest inflation
fighter that we've ever seen you know
inflation is under the tables under the
beds in the closets uh where of course
in 2021 chairman Powell said oh
inflation oh it's transient it's
temporary it's not anything permanent so
it's sort of uh the swing has gotten way
too far and
um you know as a result he is causing
far more fluctuations in the economy
than I think are warranted I think our
economy is inherently strong I think the
American system is inherently strong
um and
um I I hate to see our Central Bank
pursue policy that destabilizes the
economy
now when asked about rate Cuts sometime
in 2023 chairman Powell said essentially
no their focus is is not on any Cuts
what do you think because you're saying
that's actually probably not going to
happen that they might have some sort of
rude awakening
um it sounds like chair Powell is
looking for some job layoffs it sounds
like he's looking at the job sector for
that indication is there something else
other than uh you know an uptick in the
unemployment or you know an increase in
unemployment that would that would serve
as that rude awakening so we don't have
to get to the the point where we have
layoffs
well I think we're going to have layoffs
um and I I wish I would say no but I I
think the job market is going to weaken
considerably uh part of it was I think a
lot of firms over hired last year
because uh there was such a shortage of
Labor
um and they worried and they they took
in a lot of people that haven't been as
productive as they could have been and
that's one reason why productivity went
down a record amount uh this year
um I think a lot of them could actually
get rid of some of those people that
aren't working out as well uh and that
could be a signal to Chairman Powell
that he does not need to tighten any
further that said the FED eventually
gets it if not on time or sooner uh
later I think the market is uh you know
beginning to tell them listen you're too
tight you're going to squeeze inflation
into deflation and you're going to turn
what could be a good economy into a bad
economy that's what happens when yields
on long-term interest rates go down the
way they have so he's not convincing the
markets that his approach is right at
all in my opinion
finally Professor you are optimistic
um what is this optimism based on what
are the fundamentals that you think make
this a much stronger economy than maybe
some of our leadership and even some of
us are seeing if Fox News polling has
people feeling pretty gloomy
um yeah what would you point to and say
look that we're actually in better shape
well you know again
um I think that 2023 will turn out
better once the FED recognizes and I
think that they will that they are too
tight I think one has to realize the
inherent strengths of our market economy
I mean you take a look around the world
look what's happening in China
unbelievable crazy policy I'm not even
going to mention uh Russia elsewhere
look at Europe over regulated uh despite
our problems we are still the heart of
capitalism and we're still we're
Innovative people want to be and we have
an opportunity with some reform in our
H-1B visa system to actually get the
best and brightest from around the world
we we've got to maintain that position
Wharton Professor Jeremy Siegel thank
you so much for joining us
thank you
[Music]
and now that's some good news with Tanya
J Powers
this weekend wreath laying ceremonies
are planned across the country to
remember Fallen service members during
the holiday season one of the largest
will be at Arlington National Cemetery
in Washington D.C where thousands of
volunteers will lay the wreaths at the
graves of each veteran there as part of
the wreaths Across America program it
started in 1992 and since then more than
14 million wreaths have been sent to
locations including National cemeteries
and Veterans memorials this year the
story of the wreaths is taking on an
extra layer of Honor in December of 2021
Volunteers in Uvalde Texas worked to
make sure all the veterans buried at
Hillcrest Cemetery had a wreath on their
grave a big undertaking it took a lot of
work but after the May 24th school
shooting at Robb Elementary that took
the lives of 19 students and two
teachers the community Unity put their
wreath project for 2022 on hold that's
when volunteers from Alton Illinois
stepped in to make sure there were
enough wreaths to honor not only their
local veterans but those buried in
Uvalde too the U.S Senate unanimously
passed a resolution designating Saturday
as National wreaths Across America day
and events are planned at more than 3
100 locations in all 50 states at Sea
and abroad Tanya J Powers Fox News
[Music]
100 meteorologists and a worldwide
resources of fox in your hands with the
fox weather podcast precise personal
powerful subscribe and listen now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary to Roy Murdoch
what's on your mind White flags are
flapping in the breeze thanks to
Republicans willing to accept as
permanent the emergency election rules
that Democrats demanded during 2020's
covet hell longing for The elusive Red
Wave some GOP officials and operatives
now suffer Stockholm syndrome they think
it's time to surrender to Democrats
swallow their dodgy vote schemes and
eventually sync them with early mail-in
and traffic ballots drop boxes ballots
received and counted days and weeks
after polls close
Etc rather than switch Republicans
should fight they have nothing less than
federal law and the U.S Constitution on
their side the GOP should litigate this
matter all the way to the Supreme Court
before ever yielding the Democrats
diabolical vision of how Americans
should vote election day is the Tuesday
after the first Monday in November not
thanks to The Star-Spangled Banner or
something that Thomas Jefferson quipped
as Madera two Federal statutes govern
this matter according to two U.S code
section 7 and I quote the Tuesday next
after the first Monday in November in
every even numbered year unquote is the
date for electing members of Congress
and quadrennialy per three U.S code
section one presidential delegates to
the Electoral College these laws specify
November not October or September
neither statute allows for voting on
Halloween or just after Americans leave
the sand dunes on Labor Day meanwhile
Pennsylvania's absentee Congressional
votes started on September 16th
according to vote.org Kentucky's two
days of early voting began on November
3rd Connecticut allows neither in-person
early votes nor no excuse absentee
ballots problem these widely varied
intervals deny voters equal protection
under the 14th Amendment to the US
Constitution if Americans all voted on
Election Day as we overwhelmingly did
from the days of Andrew Johnson through
Lyndon Johnson until about when Obama
arrived voters and their ballots would
enjoy something much closer to equal
protection than today's confounding
collection of conflicting voting Windows
the these objections aside Mass mail-in
ballots early voting and all that are
odious on their merits democrats should
be ashamed of themselves by seducing
millions of Americans into voting at
home rather than at precincts Democrats
have destroyed the sanctity of the
secret ballot standing alone behind a
curtain and picking one's poles at the
polls is totally different from voting
at the kitchen table or at an office
vote party as family friends co-workers
or even employers hover judgmentally
likewise filling a mail-in ballot
beneath the Gaze of a visiting party
hack trafficker demolishes secrecy early
voting resembles a jury deliberating
before hearing all the evidence in
Pennsylvania
635 428 voters mailed in their ballots
before Democrat John fetterman's
disastrous debate against Republican
Amendment Oz
some voted as early as 39 days before
fetterman struggled to speak a key
senatorial skill
those which should change their early
ballots were out of luck rather than
surrender to Mark Elias and the
Democrats other lawfare soldiers who
cooked this dog's breakfast Republicans
need a lawyer up and litigate with all
the passion that Thurgood Marshall
brought to Brown versus Board of
Education and others devoted to Miranda
row kilo Dobbs and other landmark cases
and if such litigation fails then and
only then should Republicans discuss
beating Democrats at the filthy illegal
electoral practices that they have
sicked on America's voters
foreign
[Music]
and now stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
listen ad free on FOX News podcasts Plus
on Apple podcasts and Prime members can
listen to the show ad free on Amazon
music and for up to the minute news go
to foxnews.com
from the Fox News podcasts Network FOX
News rewind financial crisis 08 a look
back at the biggest financial crisis
since the Great Depression the market is
not functioning properly subscribe now
at foxnewspodcasts.com